[Music]
hello H how you doing hi welcome to the
Live Lab I can give you a little bit of
a of a tour one of the things that we do
in the Live Lab that is so unique we
want to know what's happening inside
people when they're musicians when
they're playing and how audiences react
so we'll put EEG caps on audience
members and on uh performers and motion
capture which is what we're going to do
with you today and study in detail
what's happening in people's brains and
in term and in their body movements uh
to figure out how do you communicate
with each other you should be able to
swing that
[Music]
around it still works I'm going to put
this uh some markers on your body on
your joint and then we can later just
use computer to connect those dots as a
as a line so you have the
[Music]
skeleton all right want you give me a
smile and relax and now frown for me
it's good now
surprise good okay they're all staying
that's good
great
it has attention good it's good yeah
okay then I think we're ready to
go okay so you're going to be playing
some happy and some sad because emotion
has two main Dimensions so one is
positive negative but the other is how
active it is or how calm it is okay
good
[Music]
n
[Applause]
[Music]